all right welcome everybody it is
another day and we are waiting on
another press conference from Donald
Trump
oh my graphics are all messed up that's
weird I don't know what's going on with
that let's see if they if they resolve
on their own huh very strange well in
any case we are waiting on on on Donald
Trump again teasing a major announcement
let's see if I can fix that
I go here huh no the gret something
something is up with the graphics today
that's very disappointing I don't I mean
a weird box but there's no graphics
around me strange alright well we will
just have to deal with it I suppose I
don't know what else there is that that
can be done we are so Donald Trump
teased some kind of major FDA related
announcement today and of course it's
anyone's guess whether we believe that
it'll really be major if I had to say I
would guess that the announcement is you
know there are people think he's going
to announce some kind of cure I don't
think so although the chloroquine
treatments do seem to be working very
very well in a number of different
studies and I'll talk about that in a
little bit my guess is Trump's going to
announce some kind of fast-tracking
infrastructure or something like that I
would not I I would be shocked if it was
anything anything bigger than that we
have the stock market now down about 1%
oh so some of the graphics are still
working but not all of them that's
interesting let's see if I do see what
happens here oh there we go I just fixed
it beautiful beautiful we're back on
we're back in business the Dow is now
down about 0.1% let me see if I can get
that live YouTube ticker
let's see Dow Jones live ticker and here
it is putting all of it just getting
everything together for you guys that
the timing of today's stream is a little
wacky because we've we had to film the
show and then all sorts of other stuff
all happening together ok we will get
that put together we've got the Yahoo
Finance and then we will pull up the
intraday so anyway yeah
the most likely announcement from Trump
is not you know as big as some people
are hoping for and me at me as well I
mean I would love to have some kind of
major announcement but it's probably
some kind of fast tracking so that
treatments or something can be put
together more quickly and streamlined
let let's talk about in a moment I'm
going to talk to you about maybe the
most promising treatment that we found
so far and this is really really good
news but first let me read a couple of
the super chats that have been coming in
via YouTube welcomed on YouTube twitch
and Facebook live we have been on all
three platforms all week bringing you
the various press conferences Jason
Aldridge says how will this impact
presidential campaigning and rallies
well the primary is over Tulsi just
dropped out and endorsed by Dhin and
Bernie has said he's reassessing and
it's just a matter of time until he
drops out so the primary is over for the
general election I don't know yet it's
it's too early
really to know Josh Gibson says good
morning from Colorado Springs our
governor has now limited gatherings to
groups of 10 schools closed until April
17 feels like a nightmare it is one it
is one but we've got to do it we've got
to do it max says similar to putting
manufacturers of ventilators on 24/7
production in is biochemical academia
pausing research projects to focus on
the pandemic I don't know the answer to
that but it would be quite sensible to
be doing that it would be quite sensible
to be doing that let me say thank you
over on twitch to Jay shadi who has
subscribed as well as Lucas rules 70 who
has subscribed with twitch prime we do
have as we have had for all these
streams a 25 new member goal at join
pakman.com coupon codes available
question to people in the chat do you
believe that the Tulsi followers will
follow her direction and vote Biden now
that she has suspended and endorsed by
Dhin who thinks that that that they will
actually do that that is an interesting
question as a hypetrain
starts on Twitch a lot of people saying
oh that the tool seized will not vote
Biden that's interesting people
wondering if Tulsi might be vide ins VP
I would not hold my breath for that I
would not hold my breath for that okay
let's talk about the most promising
treatment information so far okay
so there have been a lot of different
ideas being tested for treating
coronavirus as we wait for a vaccine
there are various antivirals one called
a began and another called REM des aveer
those are being tested there are some
antibody treatments being considered but
right now increasingly one of the most
exciting and I use that term as much as
it can apply to a tragedy is
hydroxychloroquine or chloroquine which
are two different versions of the same
medication and incredibly combined with
as if throw Meissen now is if throw
Meissen many of you might know as
zithromax it's an antibiotic and you
might be saying David what why are we
why are we using an antibiotic to treat
a virus it doesn't make sense
interestingly the azithromycin appears
to help not because it works on a virus
but because as a thorough Meissen has an
antiviral mechanism in the lungs
specifically this has been tested with
Co Co Co PD patients so this is a French
doctor and biologist so we're talking
about an MD and PhD in biology dd a
route and he has been doing small Santas
with chloroquine and he now has a new
one that is chloroquine combined with as
if through Meissen finding excellent
excellent results you can actually email
him directly he posts his email and he
is also on Twitter and the conclusion is
despite its small sample size our survey
shows that hydroxychloroquine treatment
is significantly associated with viral
load reduction and disappearance in Koga
19 patients and its effect is reinforced
by as if thrown
Elon Musk has been tweeting about this
because Elon Musk when he had malaria
was was given chloroquine chloroquine is
a 1934 drug that has been used to treat
malaria for a long time so Elon Musk has
been tweeting about this it appears as
though China has been significantly
relying on chloroquine to treat patients
and may be partially responsible for the
drastically improving numbers there
I read although I haven't confirmed this
I don't want to give incorrect
information but it may be true you can
you can google that South Korea has also
had success with chloroquine and if
indeed chloroquine combined with
azithromycin is effective the the idea
is we've got to start testing this in a
larger cluster maybe Seattle sooner than
later
and again the Elon Musk malaria thing
was a long time ago but for people who
think that this is that Elon Musk now
has malaria the these are approved
medications importantly now these would
be off-label uses a chloroquine is and
chloroquine in combination with a z-pack
it is not approved for treating kovat 19
but the idea is if these are at least
medications that already exist you would
much more quickly be able to move
forward on that is that related to what
Donald Trump is going to announce today
I have no idea I have absolutely no idea
and we we may not know I believe again
that Donald Trump is most likely to be
announcing some kind of regulatory
framework that will make it easier to
get treatments or drugs tested or
approved I know he's been teasing it for
today as some major FDA related
announcement if he's calling it an FDA
announcement my guess would be that it's
related to fast tracking or something
something along those lines but we will
soon see scheduled for 2 minutes ago
these have all been running late but
hopefully soon they are they are going
to get started we just don't know
exactly how long it'll take okay
other super chats coming in a rolous
says David did you see Bernie's response
to Manu Raju yeah he said something like
I'm dealing with an effing pandemic or
something when Manu asked when Bernie is
being out or something like that no no
seems like a reasonable question mike
says my town limited gatherings 20.5
people and has begun tearing us asunder
yeah that's smart divide people into two
pieces and then you'll really reduce the
transmission Warren birch and Lisa
Ramsey have grabbed YouTube
subscriptions and Mark Davis says David
if we get a vaccine for this how are we
gonna get the anti vaccine ground this
time yeah you know I actually I actually
tweeted yesterday let me pull up my
Twitter account I tweeted yesterday
where was it it's hard to find
anti-vaxxers and libertarians these days
the anti-vaxxers are actually more or
less behaving I know that there are some
who are still doing anti vaccine on
sense but they've been they've been
pretty quiet I asked earlier today any
predictions about Trump's big FDA
announcement what do people think it's
going to be I asked will Trump be making
a principled defiant announcement at
11:00 today based on something he either
misheard or misunderstood it was only a
matter of time until the virus was
blamed on the Jews that's happening now
as well and of course
tulsi suspends and endorses Biden Oh
people asking by the way about beta mail
I'm sorry data mail t-shirts we now have
a data male t-shirt available on david
pakman.com this was designed by one of
our viewers this is the shirt right here
I ordered a sample and I will be wearing
it on streem coming up soon data so we
now actually have that t-shirt available
in a number of different colors I tried
to pick all colors that would be good
contrast with the graphic oh this one's
not so good we might have to rethink
that one but I like the shirt in in gray
in grey it's a good one and of course we
are all focused on data these days
because that is what matters okay
we are standing by that's david
pakman.com slash gear by the way let's
do this every five new members today so
5 10
fifteen twenty twenty five you'll get a
free data mail t-shirt or item of your
choice it doesn't have to be the data
mail t-shirt but I love the data mail
t-shirt and so what will offer those
every five every five members grab a
membership at join pakman.com ok I want
to say thanks to schism age for
subscribing with twitch Prime at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman Josh ring
says thoughts on Maxine Waters relief
proposal I'm not up to speed on what she
proposed Josh I there's been a lot of
proposals lately and I don't know
exactly which is hers but you know some
things gonna have to get passed and
pretty soon at the rate that that we're
going em grace as I work as an IC at a
local food delivery business having week
bronchial tubes I am terrified to go to
work but I'm afraid to lose my job they
just sent an email to wave our workers
comp what to do I would consult with a
lawyer I don't I don't know pear tieran
says what happened with the stream the
other day the craziest thing happened
yesterday I stepped away to refill my
water during the press conference
yesterday and when I came back my entire
system had rebooted and as you know
we've decentralized production I've now
working out of a home studio and all
sorts of stuff I don't know what
happened but my my computer was on the
login screen when I came back and the
entire stream had been pinched off very
weird very very strange and at that
point the thing was almost over so we
didn't go back Marika says you were
right hunters with Al Pacino on Amazon
is good have you seen the man in the
high castle yes of course I have corona
isolation entertainment Charlie says is
it gonna be upper Trump or downer Trump
today you know lately it's been kind of
balanced Trump it hasn't been I guess
more downer than upper for sure let me
say thanks to Pitta like this like it is
PPT like it is who subscribed with prime
as well as our Rhino double zero who has
subscribed for seven months with prime
ruinin on says how's Pat
doing well no coronavirus so far and
what are the details on the proposed
White House stimulus still waiting on
those details
Walker Anderson says you were saying
Chinese virus is xenophobic how do you
differentiate from the Spanish flu does
the Shi regime not bear responsibility
for concealing um listen Chinese virus
is not in and of itself xenophobic but
it is being used in a way to make the
focus Chinese people rather than
anything else the Spanish flu started in
either Kansas France or somewhere else
so the idea that we just call things the
name that aligns with where it
originated is wrong because the China
the Spanish flu didn't originate in
Spain I actually think that this entire
Chinese flu thing is a distraction and
it's letting Trump take control of the
narrative and taking any minute spent on
Chinese flu ignores Trump's bungled
reaction and what needs to be done right
now including social distancing so I
think we should be even even as people
on the Left who find the entire Chinese
flu thing ridiculous I think we should
be careful about focusing too much on it
I did one story yesterday about kung flu
a White House official referring to it
as the come flu to an Asian reporter and
mentioned Chinese virus we've got to be
social distancing working on treatments
etc and I think it's by and large
becoming a distraction NIC Brancato is a
new Youtube subscriber Doug Parker is a
new YouTube or an upgraded Youtube
subscriber Maru Tellez says cool Jack
Maxwell says I'd bet Trump takes uppers
and downers and black wave 54 says I got
the bill key with the 50 uh free smoke
free smoke uh-uh-uh
anyone can get it blood jus heard that I
don't understand that I don't understand
let me say thank you to Brendan Taylor
brendan is new member number one today
at join pakman.com Brendan getting a
beautiful hundred and twenty dollar a
year membership very very much
appreciate that and I see people
starting to order the data mail
which are now available at david
pakman.com slash gear I know some people
are saying that it's very gender centric
data mail it should be data person but
the joke is it's a play on beta mail
which is a funny thing that some
right-wingers like to say about you know
people who think and so it's got it kind
of has to be mail because otherwise we
lose the we lose the the gimmick but it
is a data male t-shirt I have a I have I
ordered a white sample in size small
that's my size it's a very beta size I
know but it's a highly data size as well
and you can also get it this the banana
cream is just a delicious color
absolutely delicious so those are gonna
start shipping out I see that the people
are starting to order those it started
as just a joke but people do seem to
like them who ordered the shirts so far
Anthony Marks has grabbed a data male
t-shirt and Maxton Iannone has grabbed a
data male t-shirt as well very cool very
very cool thanks to razor 31 for
subscribing with twitch prime we are
standing by for a White House press
conference Donald Trump teasing that he
has a major FDA announcement today my
prediction is the announcement is some
kind of fast tracking for coronavirus
trials that's my guess I don't know
we'll see we will wait and see Grandma's
Boy says is Bernie going to audit votes
because of exit polls no I think
Bernie's gonna drop out soon name
withheld says my employer has laid off
200 people yesterday honestly for any
person lucky to still have a job will be
tightening their belts this is going to
be a big economic downturn for sure
Lenna 'the four lows and they've insured
paid leave for confirmed infections and
primary caregivers with children home
because schools and daycares are closed
seth Barham says china staged nighttime
fighter drills buzzing taiwan on monday
can you see china and possibly russia
taking advantage of the world chaos I
don't want to foment any ideas but it
would not be
huge shock to me to see that happen it
would not be a huge shock to see all
sorts of actors try to take advantage of
this in many ways if you're just joining
us on YouTube make sure to LIKE the
stream and to hit that subscribe button
thanks to your help we've surged from
eight hundred and fourteen thousand to
eight hundred and sixteen thousand
YouTube subscribers which is great
definitely make sure to LIKE and
subscribe when you come in we are 11
minutes late currently on this white
house coronavirus press briefing they
tend to start late yesterday started
almost or maybe even more than a half
hour late 3035 minutes late which is
which is unfortunate the latest official
coronavirus numbers are two hundred and
twenty eight thousand globally that is
an incredibly low number in reality very
very low the real number is far higher
the idea is here even in the United
States where we officially have about
10,000 cases we may have a hundred
thousand we may have five hundred
thousand we may have a million cases
that you know that this is just the
reality what we want to pay attention to
you know here there's a very very good
video let me see if I can actually find
it Sal Khan coronavirus ah let's see
here this is the this is the wrong thing
where is that video that I sent I
actually sent it I sent it to my brother
and my dad this is actually a really
good video that we should all we don't
have to look at it all right now but I
would check it out let me see here ah
here it is okay so this is this let's
just look at a little bit of this very
briefly just while we're waiting here
the goal of this video is to help us all
estimate the actual new kovat 19 cases
per day in your area and it's based on
analysis by Thomas Pueo
he wrote an incredible blog post on
medium this is the link and I'll also
include it in the description below this
is the data that he was
once again could be found here this is
all his analysis were based off of his
analysis but this shows you what was
happening in Hubei province which is the
province where Wuhan is and there's
several interesting things here the
vertical axis is the number of cases and
what we see in the horizontal axis is
per day and so for example we could pick
January 23rd the yellow bar tells us the
number of confirmed new cases that day
so these are people who would have been
tested and then they tested positive and
it looks like that number is about 300
but then we have this gray bar this gray
bar is the actual number of new cases
that day which is close to 2500 so
roughly eight times as high now you
might be saying how did they know the
actual number of cases if they didn't
test every one well the way they did
that is when someone tested positive
they asked them when did you first get
the symptoms right and if they said hey
I first got the symptoms ten days ago
they would be included as a true new
case an actual new case ten days before
that On January 13 so that Chinese
officials were able to actually make
these gray bars in hindsight based on
when people said they first got the
symptoms and there's a lot of really
interesting information here first of
all we can see that Wuhan was shut down
on January 23rd so let's draw a line
between the pre shut down and post shut
down and you can see just as the city
officials we're starting to see
confirmed cases the actual cases were
far higher but then they shut down the
city essentially significantly slowing
down the spread rate and a few days
later so to give you this sort of
conclusion because this this goes on for
ten minutes and this is a Khan Academy
video the gray bar shows that the real
new cases started going down as soon as
the shutdown took place you only know
that in retrospect because when you're
testing people you're testing people who
have already had symptoms for some time
so if I test you on day one you likely
actually caught the virus on day you
know minus 5 or minus 7 so the point is
we're not going to know until later when
we've actually turned the corner and
that's ok because it will hopefully just
encourage people to be even more
cautious we don't want to know right
away when we've turned the corner
because then people will immediately
stop social distancing and they'll stop
taking all the precautions they're
supposed to check
the entire video Sal Khan is very very
good at explaining this stuff and I
encourage you to check that check that
video out okay let me say thanks to a
few other new people
Gerald Decker is new member number two
today at join pakman.com uh let's see
who else am i miss okay Gerald Decker
Chris Warwick is new member number three
at join pakman.com rich Evy is new
member number four at join pakman.com
and Ian stone is new member number five
Ian you get a free t-shirt from the
David Pakman show online store contact
me through my website contact form I
said every five every five new members
you can get a free item from my online
store these are flying off the shelves
the data mail t-shirts and I just saw
that Sean Mahoney has grabbed a data
mail t-shirt and the t-shirts are flying
off the shelves I'll be wearing one soon
and every five new members you can pick
an item from my online store doesn't
have to be the data mail t-shirt you can
get a coffee mug or really whatever you
want we are 15 minutes late to this
press conference that Donald Trump
promised would have a major announcement
from the FDA my prediction is it it'll
be an announcement about some kind of
fast tracking of of clinical trials let
me say thank you to Jessica who has
subscribed for three months with twitch
prime let me say thank you to doc the
Guru who has subscribed for two months
with prime and says good day and also
thanks to Dre 33 for a cheering a
hundred bits ok other super chats
continuing to come in let's see here
first name last name has grabbed a soy
boy membership on YouTube
Walker Anderson says after Chinese virus
comes up in Trump presser you say it's
full of xenophobia
now you say Trump is attacking the
Chinese people not she seriously listen
Walker I've already said the entire
Chinese virus thing is a distraction and
I don't know that we gain much from
continuing to talk about it so I won't
Jason Johnson says subscribe to the
David Pakman show david's reasonable
voice is what we need in these hard
times thanks Jason and I'll shoot you
back
20 bucks afterwards like we agreed for
sending that super chat that's a joke by
the way
Jeff the god of biscuits says Lenna 'the
valkyrie profile is the best RPG ever
fight me on it yeah you know one of the
things I'm thinking of doing and I would
love to hear from people in the chat
about whether you think this is a good
idea is when impeachment started we
postponed a David Pakman show chess
tournament because we were doing like
eight hour streams every day and it was
just crazy and I said we'll revisit it
at some point it seems now that now that
everybody is hopefully stuck at home by
choice it would be a great time to do it
we don't have any presidential
Democratic primary debates coming up we
just have these briefings so I think
that this would be a good time to resume
the chess tournament we would probably
do it at something like 8:00 or 9:00
p.m. Eastern Time because I think that
that there's no time that would be good
for everybody if we do it at this time
it's too early for people on the west
coast if we do it at 6:00 p.m.
well West Coast people wouldn't be
working at 6:00 p.m. I mean everybody's
working from home mostly so maybe that
would work but it might start to get
late for Europe anyway it would probably
be some time between 7:00 and 9:00 p.m.
Eastern and we would I would stream
myself playing in my own chess
tournament on YouTube twitch and
Facebook anybody who wants could
participate it seems like a good it
seems like a good good thing to do now
that a lot of us are self-quarantine
eing and isolating and all of that stuff
so all um I'll make an announcement
about that when we have that rescheduled
if you are just joining us Tulsi Gabbard
has dropped out of the presidential race
and has endorsed Joseph R Biden Jr
surprising a lot of people who expected
her to endorse Bernard Sanders of course
remember that Bernie has no chance so it
would be kind of weird at this point to
start backing Bernie earlier would have
been the time to do that for sure let me
just make sure that I've successfully
uploaded all of my files today to Pat
because we are distancing want to make
sure all of today's show is over to Pat
so he can edit while while we are
watching the
press conference and all that stuff
looks like we are good what's today the
19th ABCD yeah we're in good shape good
all right so while we're streaming here
whoa I was crazy
well we're streaming here Pat can get
started on editing very very important
okay we are standing by for a Trump
press conference potentially with some
kind of major FDA related announcement
from Donald Trump Twitty
sends a $10 super chat and says thank
you thank you
Beezus Christ says khanacademy David I
posted this on your subreddit yes the
the video we were just watching from Sal
Khan is indeed a Khan Academy video and
it is it is a good one
Asad khatib has grabbed the YouTube
membership D works Minh has as well as
has Twitty and Dave harder mike says
wouldn't saying free stuff at subscriber
x cause every subscription before that
to wait and slow things down maybe
randomize okay yeah let's do that let's
do that so I will be tweet so we've got
20 members to go to get 225 instead of
numbers 10 15 and 20 and 25 getting a
free item from my store
I will pick for more random people to
get the items that way you don't people
might be waiting to Steiners to sign up
okay Oh Mike Steinberg hey Mike Mike
Mike's a good friend of mine Mike is a
new member I got to send him a data male
t-shirt Mike is new member number 6 hope
you're doing now there are multiple
Steinberg family members who are
subscribers to the David Pakman show
hope you guys are doing well Mike I'll
give you a call soon let's see here also
Daniel Mulaney has grabbed a
subscription and a subscriber number 7
today and I will do I'll just randomly
gift t-shirts and and stuff like that
again the data male t-shirt is now
available
I let me see if I can even find while
we're waiting this is gonna be tough to
find
when Jesse Lee Peterson called me beta
Jesse Lee Peterson
Pakman bata let's see if I can find it
let's see nope that's not it
no I'm having trouble finding I wish I
could find this for you guys but I am
I'm there's there's like a couple
remixes where Jesse Lee Peterson calls
me beta and it's pretty funny but I
can't find it it's just I I wish I had
it prepared I will play for you just as
a funny goof
well good we're just waiting here for
Trump here is when I got kicked off of
Jesse Lee Peterson's show and I was I
guess I was being obstinate according to
him let me see here where was this oh
okay here it is go conservative David
answer that question are you is that
progress it's not an example of
something that is or isn't progress but
the reason I'm asking whether you're a
fiscal conservative yo this is sped up
I'm sorry let me slow it down real quick
and don't we're not gonna miss the Trump
speech don't worry we're just kind of
killing time here cause it's cheaper
it's cheaper okay for those procedures
why don't you discharge to find and
discharge every transgender member of
the military so if you're a fiscal
conservative never heard you say that
you are you should favor the cheaper we
have those procedures and not paying for
it would cost to find and discharge all
those chapters
Daivari members gave it you're not here
to communicate I really appreciate you
coming on I'm gonna let you go it's a
waste of time to talk to you we're not
communicating you acted like that
because you're asking bizarre questions
you're the idiot and you're waiting my
time appreciate Mon Ami all right they
never coming see you bye goodbye let him
go that's a progressive folks all men
who are progressive of males who are
progressive or weak people yeah they are
weak people and what have these people
aren't it doesn't even make sense well
he had asked his producer to book me
funny come to communicate because
they're too insecure and David Pakman is
a very insecure
progessive real men are not progressive
right
I'm progressive whatever they are that's
not the nature of a man I don't even
know why you guys invited a guy back
amazing hilariously when I was in LA for
the I don't know if it was in LA in LA
when I was doing Rogen's show or in LA
when I was doing politican I went in
person - Jesse Lee's studio and all of
his producers wanted pictures with me
they were all clearly fans and some of
them were like more willing to admit it
than others some of them are playing
cool and it oh hold on a second we've
got a band some people for anti semitism
just excuse me one moment folks there we
go sorry we just had to just needed a
quick band there the ban hammer was
dropped down anyway yeah like all those
producers who were perfectly nice people
we're asking me for pictures and stuff
like that it was hilarious okay let me
say thank you to a few other new members
gustas Zola is new member number eight
today thanks gustas Shane bean is new
member number nine today and Esteban
Kenneth is new member number ten today
certainly no beta males there that's for
absolute that's absolutely clear also
Andrew LaRoque is new member number
eleven today does anybody know why these
press conferences always start like half
an hour to an hour late I I simply
cannot understand for the life of me why
they are always so delayed and it's very
very strange very very weird okay Owen
Gobbo says tulsi drops out and backs
Biden says Fox News true false true as
far as I know I tweeted a byte about it
a lot of a lot of burners are upset
about that Beezus Christ says I'd rather
watch you play a video game than chest
you boomer come on man were around the
same age played divinity original sins -
I have not even heard of divinity
original sins - is that like a version
of Monopoly Charlie says thanks for the
wicked smaht analysis David thank you
who
else here sorry just the these scrolled
up here Leanne Amanda Anderson says
David do you believe kovat 19 was
created it was created by man it can be
destroyed by man no I don't a lot of you
might find this shocking but I don't
think kovat 19 was a bio weapon created
by kim jeong-hoon
or the jews or any of the theories that
we've heard so far
North Side Irish says late again mormor
entha or smashing potatoes I don't know
what that means
fix it Scottie and user have both
grabbed YouTube subscriptions Bruce
broomsticks and hammers has as well
blind man says what says thank you David
Pakman bunnell ii yeah my new i am now
going to be streaming under the handle
David Kenneth destiny bunnell the second
that's going to be my new my new handle
but it all all joking aside this is now
no longer funny it was funny when it
happened so a few weeks ago Stephen
Kenneth widely known twitch superstar
Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell the
second as well as Hasan destiny [ __ ]
the second and Raj Raj Royale fame they
were all in town for PAX East and I very
rapidly found out that Raj was ill and
at the time I don't know if it was the
flu or a corona or what it was he I he
were talking about hanging out and I
immediately kibosh that because it's I
couldn't I just couldn't chance it that
was gonna be on Saturday on Sunday I
went to brunch with Stephen Kenneth
destiny bonel ii as well as a couple
people from his streaming community and
and and Kenneth's girlfriend and I was
like okay Oh
okay looks like we're starting soon I
was uh I thought I was in the clear for
contagion and then I found out that all
of the previous night Kenneth had been
with Raj so it's like I was exposed at
that point but that was like a month ago
so I do think that I'm okay
are we are now standing by in any second
we are expecting a major announcement
from Donald Trump and FDA related
announcement again I predict that the
announcement is going to be that there's
some kind of fast tracking for for
treatment I don't I don't expect
anything more major than that okay let's
make sure I don't fall behind on
anything okay oh did I did I say Esteban
Kenneth isn't it I didn't realize the
joke there Esteban Kenneth grabbed a
membership that's funny I didn't even
realize that okay folks are going to be
coming in here Michael home says I'm
from South Africa and the crazy Chinese
ambassador blamed the u.s. for koban 19
here in South Africa we've only tested
three thousand people it's bad
Jeannie Harini says is a new website
member or a YouTube member sweet baby
blade foot is a new member
Kowalski from Nebraska how much corn do
you want for a shirt I got beef - that's
interesting I would take you know if
it's grass-fed I would trade a data male
t-shirt Kowalski what's a reasonable
amount I mean if I don't need anything
crazy a few six ounce nice grass-fed six
ounce steaks I would probably trade I
eat red meat very infrequently but I
would I would take a nice grass-fed
steak from you Randall gret singer is a
new YouTube member Carlos odo Gil says
any comments on how am low hazard hasn't
been handling the situation in Mexico I
really don't know much about the Mexican
handling so I don't I'm not really able
to say I don't want to comment beyond my
area of expertise
Twitty says movie ticket for Pakman show
yes my last name doesn't have a C in it
that's the one thing about it so here we
see the Surgeon General dr. Burks I
don't remember who this guy is who else
is coming in
whoo there's like a high-pitched squeal
in the room someone's got to get that
feedback under control Oh dr. Burks did
not like where this dude was standing
and pointed him over to a different spot
I'll keep the NBC stream going as well
because sometimes the White House stream
volume is just so low so we will I
always like to have a backup stream just
in case yeah it looks like this reporter
also heard that very high-pitched squeal
in the room that was weird
oh he was blocking the flag right you
don't want to block the flag that's true
remember if you're just joining on
YouTube to hit like and subscribe
somehow there's 6,000 people watching on
YouTube and only 700 likes which is sad
remember to like and subscribe here in
advance of a major major announcement an
FDA related announcement social
distancing happening right on stage
oh and date nobody likes where that guy
is standing they should just you know
that the smart thing to do oh the
Surgeon General was off screen
altogether they should just mark X's
with tape on the floor that's the way a
lot of times it's done now this guy's
blocking the flag again I don't know if
I like that yeah I don't like you know
the Surgeon General he's standing a
little too close to dr. Burks and I
don't like that I would like to see him
a little further off that that's that's
concerning and he's like all puffed up
to that right arm of his is dangerously
close to dr. Burks he's kind of
spreading his arms where she's
collapsing them to take up as little
space as possible often happens often
happens let me say thanks to Andriy
Pichet who is new member number 12 today
at join pakman.com appreciate that there
now this is Trump right I think that's
Trump thank you let's take a listen I
think there's gonna be a very important
conference I hope so and I'll get to
that toward the middle but I have a few
things to report
want to thank you all for being here and
I have to say I think with social
distancing it's been much nicer I don't
know what it is all these empty fees in
between chairs we probably shouldn't
have anybody sitting behind you either
you know I should probably go back but I
love it it's so much nicer but I
shouldn't say that because you'll get me
now right thank you all for being here
and we continue our relentless effort to
defeat the Chinese virus the invisible
Tory I don't want to start by announcing
that today we are bringing home another
American citizen it was a big thing very
big on our feet Cory is on his way back
to the United States after being
imprisoned in Lebanon since September of
2019 hmm he's battling late-stage cancer
mr. Hikari will now be able to receive
the much needed care and treatment in
the United States we've been working
very hard to get him freed then he's
finally able to have his entire family
at his side so I'm very grateful to the
Lebanese government they worked with us
and we are very proud of his family they
stood by him so strongly and they are
thrilled the United States has no higher
priority than the safety and well-being
of our citizens we've gotten a
tremendous number of hostages out as you
know I think we're 42 and oh and Robert
O'Brien as you know was chief negotiator
for a large part of it get to the corona
well that now we have him in a different
position so I want to thank and
congratulate Robert and his team and I
want to let everyone know that
recovering Americans held captive and
imprisoned abroad continues to be a top
rare anyone noticed there's fewer people
on stage each day one young gentleman
Austin Tice and we're working very hard
with Syria to get him out we hope the
Syrian government guys I think dr. Burks
just blinked the most Morse code for
held hostage by Trump we've
written a letter just recently but he's
been there for a long time and was
captured long ago Austin Tice his
mother's probably watching and she's a
great lady and we're doing the best we
can
so Syria please work with us and we
would appreciate your letting them out
of you think about what we've done we've
gotten rid of the Isis Caliphate in
Syria we've done a lot for Syria we have
to see if they're going to do this as a
we're delivering we appreciate it if
they would let Austin Tice out
immediately as you know my
administration is working every day to
protect American people and the American
economy from the virus
yesterday I signed into law a critical
support for American workers families
and small businesses a big thing we're
providing sick leave and family medical
leave to those affected by the virus and
more health is on the way as we speak
our entire team headed by secretary
minuchin is on the hill we're working
with Democrats and Republicans and
there's a lot of goodwill going on this
was something that happened that was
some people would say an act of God I
don't view it as an act of God I would
know it as something that just surprised
the whole world two months ago it
surprised people would have known about
it
it could have stopped been stopped in
place it could have been stopped right
where it came from China if we kind
known about it if they would have known
about it
but now the whole world almost is
inflicted with this horrible with this
horrible virus and it's too bad it's too
bad because we never had an economy as
good as the economy we had just a few
weeks ago all right we'll be back and I
actually think we'll be back stronger
than ever before because we learned a
lot during this period of time
I also just invoked the defense
production Act to help facilitate
distribution of essential supplies if
necessary we're working with Congress to
provide major additional relief to the
workers small businesses and the hardest
hit industries we want to make sure that
everybody is able to continue on so that
when we recover all of these companies
and these great businesses both very
very small and very very large they're
not gonna be broken up and you'd have to
put them back together that would take a
long time because we really believe in I
believe in the V curve I believe it's
going to go when this is when this is
defeated this hidden scourge is defeated
I think we're gonna go up very rapidly
our economy and get back to where it was
and beyond I think he's right today I
want to share with you exciting progress
that the FDA is making with the private
sector as we slash red tape like nobody
has ever done it before somebody was on
so its regular story or one of the
networks and said that there's never
been a president even close that's been
able to do what I've done in slashing
all of the red tape and everything to
get very important things to the market
medical elements of slash red tape to
develop vaccines and therapies as fast
as it can possibly be done long before
anybody else was even thinking about
doing this and as you know earlier this
week we began the first clinical trial
of a vaccine candidate for the virus and
that was launched in record time it was
just a few weeks and that would have
taken years to do not so long ago as we
race to develop a vaccine we're also
pursuing antiviral therapies and that's
what really we're going to be talking to
you about today that's the purpose of
being up here today let's see if there's
anything I haven't already that's even
more important than vaccine by its
nature you have to have long tests
because you have to make sure what goes
into somebody's body is not going to do
destruction bad things so you need long
tests
and they're doing great with the
vaccines but it's still a long process
but the therapies are something we can
move on much faster potentially and the
treatments that we'll be able to reduce
the severity or duration of the symptoms
make people better essentially with
looking at things to make people better
or at the very earliest stages that
wouldn't even know they had it and
that's where I believe it's going to
work even the best the FDA Commissioner
Stephen on who's with us he's fantastic
and he's been working 24 hours a day
he's been he's worked like probably as
hard or harder than anybody in this in
the group other than maybe Mike Pence or
me imagine that and what the FDA is
doing is incredible they've done things
in times that were not even thinkable
and I've directed the FDA to eliminate
outdated rules and bureaucracy so this
work can proceed rapidly quickly and I
mean fast fast and we have to remove
every barrier there were a lot of
barriers that were unnecessary and
they've done that to get the rapid
deployment of safe effective treatments
and we think we have some good answers
we'll find out very very soon clinical
trials are already underway for many new
therapies and we're working on scaling
these to allow many more Americans to
access different drugs that have shown
really good promise we've had some
really good promise we will do so in a
way that lets us continue to collect
with data to know which medicines are
safe and which medicines are working the
best we have a couple that where we're
in really good shape on
and that's for immediate delivery
immediate I guess a began and
chloroquine as fast as we can get it
the FDA has also approved compassionate
use for a significant number of patients
you know what that means we're also
reviewing drugs that are approved abroad
or drugs approved here for other uses
and you know one of the things that I'm
most proud of that I got was right to
try that's where somebody who's ill
somebody who's very sick terminally ill
usually in past administrations we
signed us a year and a half ago you
wouldn't be able to come on even think
about getting any of the drugs that may
be showing great promise now and they've
been trying for many decades to get this
approved then it sounds simple but it's
not because there's liability involved
and lots of other things right
he doesn't care fine I was able to get
it approved working with Congress right
to try this is beyond right to try what
we're talking about today is beyond
right to try right to try a spin by the
way tremendous success people are living
now that had no chance of living where
we take treatments that would do things
that that would have to go through years
of a process and if somebody was
terminally ill and I would say why
wouldn't they be able to try this Ted go
to Asia they go to Europe they'd go all
over the world to try and find something
or some people have they had no money
we'd go home today they go home today
they had no hope oh my good right to try
it's been an incredible success I think
we get it but this is beyond right to
try if treatment is known to be safe in
Europe Japan or other nations are
effective against a virus we'll use that
information to protect the health and
safety of American people nothing will
stand in our way as we pursue any Avenue
to find what best works against this
horrible virus now a drug called
chloroquine yes and some people would
add to it hydroxy hydroxychloroquine
something else laura quinn or hydroxy
tor my viewers knew about this a week
ago there's a
and malaria drug it's also a drug used
for strong arthritis somebody has pretty
serious arthritis also uses this in a
somewhat different form but it is known
as a malaria drug and it's been around
for a long time 1934 very powerful cheap
but the nice part is it's been around
for a long time so we know that if it if
if things don't go as planned it's not
going to kill anybody when you go with a
brand new drug you don't know that
that's gonna happen you have to seems
like he only learned all this up in you
in the last hour in different forms very
powerful drug in different forms and
it's shown very encouraging very very
encouraging early results and we're
going to be able to make that drug
available almost immediately and that's
where the FDA has been so great they
they've gone through the approval
process it's been approved and they did
it they took it down from many many
months to immediate so we're gonna be
able to make that drug available by
prescription or states I spoke with
Governor Cuomo about it at great length
last night and he wants to be right on
on the he wants to be first on the line
and so I think that's a tremendous as
tremendous promise based on the results
and other tests this tremendous promise
and normally the FDA would take a long
time to approve something like that and
it's it was approved very very quickly
and it's now approved by prescription
individual states will handle it they
can handle it doctors will handle it and
I think it's gonna be I think it's gonna
be great
then we're quickly studying this drug
and while we're continuing to study it
but the studying is going to be also
done in as it's given out to large
groups the sava gaps in New York and
other places will study if they're there
are promising therapies produced by
Gilead and that's from des aver where
I'm gesture for other purposes that's
been out oh my good very good results
for other purposes but it seems to have
a very good result
you got to play amount of this virus so
by the way anyone who's been watching my
show this is always you approved or very
close to approved in that case by the
FDA and I can't tell you how much we
appreciate what the FDA these people are
incredible Patriots and the job that
Stephen Han is doing dr. Han was one of
the most respected doctors in the
country by the way well we took him I
said you sure you want to do this now we
didn't know that this was going to be in
the playlist what happened here but
right he really has stepped up to the
plate
wherever you are words a [ __ ] is here
but I'm not supposed to do that oh my
god tough love I didn't but he's been
fantastic and I thank you doctor he's
gonna speak right after I'm finish so
somebody please click that Regeneron
again and some is a company that's done
fantastically well as I understand with
Ebola and some other things great
company and they're looking at some very
promising events also so you have rim
discs of voix provisional law and you
have cleric wind and I drill
hydroxychloroquine right sometimes you
breathe those are two that are out now
essentially approved for out-and-proud
of prescribed use and I think it's gonna
be very exciting I think it could be
popular game changer and maybe not and
maybe not but I think it could be
what I see a command this is amazing
very powerful they're very powerful so I
want every American to know that we're
doing everything we can and these
actions are important next steps I mean
for the FDA to act the way they acted
with this kind of speed is an incredible
thing normally they'd say well we can
have it by next year or we can have it
by in two years from now you understand
this is the way normally it's like years
and years and years they had it
immediately based on the fact that it's
been used for other things totally
unrelated things we believe these
therapeutics and others under evaluation
right now we'll be able to almost like
Trump thinks the idea of off-label uses
for medications has just been thought of
in the last 24 hours
tremendous breakthrough and we will work
toward a much needed vaccine in the
future as I said and what we're doing
with the FDA is so exciting in so many
other fields so many things are
happening it's a very exciting time for
for medicine and we appreciate that the
American public has pulled together
they're really staying home and I think
there's tremendous spirit in this
country right now spirit like a lot of
people have not seen people have not
seen anything like it for a long time
and that means democrat-republican
they're pulling together I hope
everything's going good in the hill
maybe I shouldn't say this until I check
out what's going on because you never
know but but I think there's a great
spirit where the Democrats the
Republicans and everybody else they're
getting together and they're trying to
get things done but most importantly the
American public has been incredible we
took the best economy we've ever had
and we said stop you can't work you have
to stay home you know there's never been
a case like this normally you pay a lot
of money to get things going here's a
case we were paying a lot of money to
stop things because we don't want people
to be together he's right so that this
virus doesn't continue onward
so there's never been anything like this
in history there's never been a nobody's
ever seen anything like this but we're
doing the right thing we have to get rid
of you know our big war is not a it's
not a financial war it's a war and it's
a medical war on an Indian that was the
store is very important with that I'd
like to just introduce dr. Stephen Hahn
yeah and he again I'd like to send back
with Stephen our thanks to all of the
people working to the FDA who are
fantastic talented people we appreciate
it very much everything you've done
especially the speed that you got these
two elements these two very important
drugs passed thank you very much thank
you mr. president I want to thank you
for your leadership during this corona
virus outbreak and thank you for the
kind words about the FDA staff we have
10,000 scientists doctors and others and
more than that working around the clock
to aid the American people in this fight
against the corona virus and those words
are very much appreciated sir thank you
so um before the president nominated me
and I was confirmed as commissioner from
drugs that was a cancer doctor and I've
sat across from countless number of
patients and had to talk to them about
their diagnosis and their treatment and
one thing that was really important is
to provide hope I have great hope for
how we're going to come out of this
situation what's also important is not
to provide false hope but to provide
hope and as a doctor that's the way I
come to this I'm speaking now to the
American people as commissioner of food
and drugs but that part of me has not
left just look at the way the American
people have responded to our calls for
mitigation for social distancing
American people have great
resiliency and I'm so incredibly proud
of how the American people have
responded as the president mentioned he
asked us to be aggressive to break down
barriers to innovation and to accelerate
the development of life-saving
treatments and we're doing that at the
FDA the FDA is committed to continuing
to provide regulatory flexibility and
guidance but let me make one thing clear
FDA's responsibility to the American
people
is to ensure that products are safe and
effective and yet we are continuing to
do that our folks and their tremendous
professionals are working day and night
to do this you just can't even imagine
how much they're working to provide this
support for the American people and I
thank them since early January long
before the first domestic case FDA began
working in collaboration with CDC I also
want to note that we stood up at
incident command group and have been
focused on the corona virus since the
very beginning of this public health
emergency this is in addition and all of
government and all America proach and
I'll describe what I mean by that in
terms of the development of therapeutics
an important part of that work is
expanding the potential therapeutic
options associated with coronavirus and
we've learned from our colleagues across
the globe about this but I I want to
focus on one thing I was a cancer
researcher before all this and one thing
I know about this great country of ours
is that we have unbelievable innovators
we have people who every day it's their
job to develop treatments for all sorts
of diseases we are incredibly blessed as
a country to have this and as is true in
any illness these great American
innovators academia private sector they
have engaged us about the best possible
treatment options we are looking at
everything that's coming across our
desks as possible treatment options for
coronavirus and we're extremely
encouraged by the interest and the
promise that we've seen from these great
American innovators now again we need to
look at it we need the data we need the
information to make the absolute best
decisions for American people but I want
to assure you we have over 17,000 people
at FDA who are doing this every day we
need we need to make sure that these the
see of new treatments will get the right
drug to the right patient at the right
dosage at the right time as an example
we may have the right drug but it may
not be in the appropriate dosage form
right now and that may do more harm than
good those are the things that that's
our job to look at and that's why it's
really important we have these dedicated
professionals looking at these aspects
of therapeutic
development at the same time we're also
working through different mechanisms to
actually get drugs into the hands of
providers and patients the president
mentioned this but one of the mechanisms
called compassionate use let me just
tell you about this if there's an
experimental drug that's potentially
available a doctor could ask for that
drug to be used in a patient we have
criteria for that and very speedy
approval for that the important thing
about compassionate use and that's what
the president meant this is even beyond
right to try is that we get to collect
the information about that because one
of the things with no promise the
American people is we will collect the
data and then make the absolute right
decisions based upon those data about
the safety and efficacy of the
treatments we are working expeditiously
and we are working to make sure that
these products are as safe and effective
as they possibly can be let me tell you
about a few things that we're currently
working on yes and this is a plan that
was developed with many of the people at
this table are infectious disease they
could do this one five minutes it's
getting the short term you're looking at
drugs that are already approved for
other indications right so they're
already approved as the president said
for other diseases as an example many
Americans have read studies and heard
media reports about this drug
chloroquine yes which is an
anti-malarial drug it's already approved
as the president said for the treatment
of malaria as well as an arthritis
condition that's a drug that the
president has directed us to take a
closer look at as to whether an expanded
use approach to that could be done to
actually see if that benefits patients
and again we want to do that in the
setting of a clinical trial a large
pragmatic clinical trial to actually
gather that information and answer the
question that needs to be answered and
asked and answered let me give you
another example
there's a cross-agency effort about
something called convalescent plasma
this is a pretty exciting area and again
this is something that we have given
assistance to other countries with as
this crisis has developed so FDA has
been working for some time on this if
you've been exposed to coronavirus and
you're better you don't have the virus
in your blood we could collect the blood
now this is a possible treatment yes
it's not a
proven tree talks about it eyes that
collect the blood concentrate that and
have the ability once it's pathogen free
that is virus free
be able to give that to other patients
and the immunoglobulins the immune
response could potentially provide a
benefit to patients right it's another
thing that we're looking at over the
next couple weeks we'll have more
information that we're really pushing
hard to try to accelerate that that's in
this sort of more medium short term and
that'll be a bridge to other therapies
that will take us three to six months to
develop and this is a continuous process
there is no beginning and end to each of
this this is you know we're pushing this
through the other great thing about the
great of innovators of America some of
them tell us it's taken us years years
to develop therapies they're looking at
pushing that to the months period of
time and we're trying to provide them
the regulatory flexibility but at the
same time the scientific oversight to
make sure that gets done in the best way
possible for the American people the
president mentioned that there is a
vaccine trial currently being performed
it's a phase one trial so it's the
earliest study that gets done we expect
that to take 12 months to get depletion
data at a time where we could approve a
vaccine but that's these are all things
to bridge to the prevention part of this
with a vaccine it's exciting work and
the president is right this is record
time for the development of a vaccine
and impressive public-private
partnership the FDA's efforts to
facilitate the development of these
products are focused on ensuring timely
access while also meeting the agency's
world respected gold standard relying on
strong data from clinical trials to
determine if an experimental or an
off-the-shelf drug that's used for
something else can safely and
effectively treat patients we want to
assure the American people that FDA is
all hands on deck as the president
mentioned these efforts and continue to
work with interested sponsors to help
expedite the work we remain steadfast in
helping to foster the development of
safe and effective therapies for koba 19
thank you very much
so anybody who's been watching my show
all week knew all of this done thanks
Thank You mr. president the White House
coronavirus task force met this morning
and on this very first day of springg
we continue to make steady progress
toward president Trump's objective not
only to marshal all the resources of the
federal government every state
government every every local health
official but also to harness the power
of the American private sector and
activities over the last day reflect all
of those priorities
yesterday the president spoke with
America's top physicians and nurses and
garnered helpful insights about how we
can best serve those who are serving
Americans that are dealing with the
coronavirus we also had a productive
call with over 5,000 state and local
officials explaining the federal
government's approach and our strong and
seamless partnership with all 50 states
and the territories last night as you
heard the president side the family
first coronavirus response Act which
provides free coronavirus testing
paid sick leave family leave for
caregivers and food assistance for the
needy among a broad range of benefits
and today as the president indicated we
expect that the Senate will begin work
on an economic relief package later
today the president and I will meet
again in a teleconference with the
nation's governors we will meet at the
National Response Coordination Center at
FEMA an outline president Trump's
decision to have FEMA take the lead in
our national coronavirus response our
nation's response through FEMA will be
locally executed state managed and
federally supported on testing we want
the American people to know once again
the testing is available in all 50
states as it's increasingly available
literally every hour of the day because
of the public-private partnership that
the president initiated several weeks
ago with major commercial labs I'm
pleased to receive a report today that
tens of thousands of tests are being
performed every day and with the passage
of last night's legislations
estate and private labs are now required
by law to report all coronavirus testing
directly to the CDC which will give the
American public and also give our
researchers timely and important
information it's important for every
American to remember that if you don't
have symptoms you don't need to get a
test we want to make sure the testing is
available for people that are
experiencing symptoms or they actually
finding a symptomatic having been
exposed to someone with the corona virus
dr. Burks will address county level data
as well as the progress we've made on
testing and Americans can expect to see
how an increased number of cases as our
new testing system comes online should
not be a cause of concern I shall
explain the importance of taking into
account our new testing system as new
data arrives over the next several days
on supplies a priority the president has
given to our task force we continue to
work with health care providers
businesses and state leadership to
identify available supplies not merely
in the federal stockpile but much more
importantly available across the private
sector we're encouraged to see companies
like Honeywell and 3m that I visited a
few short weeks ago take advantage of
the changes in the law last night that
allow the sale of industrial masks
directly to hospitals those companies
have now greatly increased by the tens
of millions their production of
so-called n95 masks that will give our
health care workers the protection that
they need to minister to those that are
dealing with the symptoms or the disease
of coronavirus mm-hmm following the
signing of last night's bill all of
those masks now have liability
protection and the companies can sale
industrial mat for the president we
spent a lot of time as a builder when we
thank builders across America for
partnering with our local healthcare
officials on the subject of ventilators
we're working with health care providers
around America and and suppliers and I'm
we're encouraged to learn that we've
literally identified
tens of thousands of ventilators that
Bing can be converted to treat patients
and we remain increasingly confident
that we will have the ventilators that
we need as the coronavirus makes its way
across America and as we said before
this we're all in this together
and before I step away and and give the
podium back to the president and to dr.
Burks I want to call every American's
attention again to the president's 15
days to slow the spread you continue to
hear one case after another one city
after another where people are putting
into practice the principles that the
president outlined this Monday and make
no mistake about it that while for the
American people as a whole the risk of
serious illness remains low these
guidelines should be practiced by every
American in every community not only to
lessen the spread of the coronavirus but
to protect the most vulnerable among us
and I think Americans with their with
from their hearts are not only
practicing these principles of social
distancing and avoiding social
gatherings of more than 10 people using
drive-throughs at restaurants to protect
their own health and the health of their
family but they're also recognizing that
no American wants to inadvertently
convey the coronavirus to someone for
whom the consequences could be quite
serious at the president's direction
will continue to marshal all the
resources of government at every level
we'll be reiterating that strong
partnership with America States this
afternoon with America's governors
pulling all of the private sector energy
together the innovation that you just
heard described I know on this first day
of spring that we'll get through this
and we'll get through this together
Thank You mr. okay thank you Mike thank
you very much dr. Brooks please so I
know you're watching the data carefully
you can see the dramatic increases in
the number of new cases based on our
ability to test additional people and
this will continue over the next two to
three days as we begin to have backlogs
reduced of the testing you all have
heard the
- doubts of people waiting five or six
days for their test results we are
moving through all of that as well as
testing individuals I really want to
applaud the frontline healthcare workers
the nurses and the doctors and the
testers that have really prioritized and
the American people who have a
prioritize those with symptoms the
number of tests positives is increasing
that is a dramatically important
signature that everybody is doing their
job those with mild symptoms are staying
home self isolating those with serious
symptoms are coming forward to getting
testing our tests positive rates are now
into the ten to eleven percent range
that still means that 90% of the illness
is out there even the severe ones are
not covet nineteen I know many of you
are looking at the state level data
still over 50% of the cases come from
three states this is why we continue to
prioritize testing in those states in
addition fifty percent of the cases come
from ten counties we're a very large
country with very many counties and I
just want to applaud the local and state
governments that are implementing their
emergency operation centers and plans to
ensure I want to also really thank the
healthcare workers that have been asked
to reduce all elective surgeries medical
and dental visits this will dramatically
increase the number of ventilators that
are available in hospitals but also in
ambulatory surgical centers that can be
converted and utilized and also the to
the construction industry we are deeply
grateful the number as vice president
said the number of individuals have come
forward with their construction mask
their booties their art I've X's on
suits and their masks to contribute them
to the healthcare sector the President's
request to make this available in that
legislation changes the ability and
increases our availability immediately
by than 75 to 90 percent range because
the amount of construction use
those elements thank you thank you
doctor oh thank you thank you mr.
president mr. vice president
Oh today you heard a wonderful
announcement from the FDA and I just
want to give a shout out to Steve dr.
Hahn and the folks at the FTA we're
about what several hundred of my
commissioned Corps officers work you're
right mr. president
they are tireless they're doing things
that have never been done before to
bring the most most prudent advances to
the American people but I want to talk
about something different briefly we
know many of you are home practicing the
president's guidelines for social
distancing but one thing we should all
consider especially our Millennials in
Gen Z is donating blood as an
anesthesiologist who still practices at
Walter Reed taking care of our wounded
warriors and our soldiers I know
donated blood is an essential part of
caring for patients and one donation can
save up to three lives blood centers are
open now and in need of your donation I
want Americans to know that blood
donation is safe and blood centers are
taking extra precautions at this time
based on new CDC recommendations
including spacing beds 6 feet apart
disinfecting surfaces between patient's
temperature checking staff and
encouraging donors to make appointments
ahead of time so we can space them out
social distancing does not have to mean
social disengagement so give blood today
you'll feel good about it and you'll be
helping your country and your community
during this crisis and you might even
save a life
yeah switching to the the Epis to boost
the economy with this measures for
Congress will you guarantee that the
money the billions the tens of billions
of dollars hundreds of billions of
dollars even that's gonna go but to
these industries will not go to
executive bonuses or no more stock
buybacks the question we're gonna want
that and in fact some companies as you
know did stock buybacks and I was never
happy with that it's very hard to tell
them not to but I would tell them not to
I would say I don't like it for that
reason some did and it turned out that
they coulda waited a long time it would
have been much better off if they did
the condition of the bill you can say
that none of this money can go what I'm
making
I mean you know take so many many people
in this case to tango and as far as I'm
concerned that conditions like that
would be okay with me question for you
and then a question for dr. klahn you
enabled I guess is probably the best way
to put it the defense production act
yesterday but you don't pull the trigger
on it
no because we hope we're not going to
need from the Democratic leadership to
pull the trigger on what wait what's the
rationale for not you first of all
governors are supposed to be doing a lot
of this work and they are doing a lot of
this work federal government said
supposed to be out there buying vast
amounts of items and then shipping you
know we're not a shipping clerk the
governors are supposed to be as with
testing keratoconus not shipping
supposed to be doing it will help out
and will help out wherever we can and we
can buy in volume and in some cases
great volume with the masks as an
example which were really a problem we
have helped out and they're right now
millions of masks being made but this is
really for the local governments
governors and people within the state
depending on the way they divided it up
and they'll do that and they're doing a
very good job of it where you have a
problem with ventilators we're working
very hard trying to find nobody in their
wildest dreams would have ever thought
that we need tens of thousands of
ventilators this is something that's
very unique to this to what happened
additions would you put the defense
production Act into action well if we
were desperately in need of something
and we frankly will know about that very
shortly we want to be ahead of we don't
want to do it as it happens but before
it happens we're going to know a lot
over the next two or three days we know
a lot any idea when REM disappear will
be available to the market and are there
any drugs in the pipeline that you
believe could qualify for a treatment I
obtained so with respect to the first
question I'm on prohibited by law to
disclose confidential commercial
information what I can tell you is we're
working very closely with the company on
this and we'll have additional
information they'll yet relatively soon
yes there are drugs in the pipeline
we're looking at everyone everyone on
this dais gets calls every day as to all
of our people at the FDA about potential
therapeutic options we are looking at
every single one of them
no I'm not but we're trying to find that
out this has been going on for years
many years they've been trying to find
Austin Tice he was in Syria as you know
his mother is an incredible woman and
I'm doing it for him but I'm doing it
for his mother his mother's an
incredible woman who is desperate to
find her son and I'm not confirming a
lot but if if he is alive if we would
like very much to get him back quickly
okay virus speaking of shortages of
supplies the CDC has put out guidelines
for hospitals that are dealing with a
shortage of masks to use them beyond
their shelf life reuse them instead of
getting new ones and in a worst-case
scenario use a bandana instead of a mask
how is that acceptable at all well I
haven't seen that but I will let Mike
answer that question first question I'm
happy to mr. president I just I can't
emphasize enough the incredible progress
that was made with the passage of the
legislation last night the president had
me go to Minnesota meet with 3m that
manufactures these in 95 mass a few
weeks ago and we learned of their
production at that facility of 35
million mass a month less than five
million of those were qualified to be
sold to hospitals fewer president worked
with Republican and Democrat leadership
we've extended the liability protection
so now that all the industrial masks
that are manufactured as n95 s are now
available to hospitals and we're seeing
a dramatic increase in production
Honeywell alone is repurposing a factory
that was destined for Mexico to produce
another 120 million mass per year 3m is
increasing output to 420 million masks
per year we really we've put a priority
at the president's direction on making
sure those that are providing health
care services to America have the
protection to keep themselves and their
families safe and with the legislation
last night with the incredible response
among these great private-sector
companies and as we mentioned repeatedly
with construction companies around
America heating the president's call to
donate
their industrial master hospitals is
happening all over America we know we'll
meet that need at least we start well as
I mentioned 3m is increasing their
output to 420 million a year at
production a year January they make 35
million per month at that facility and
we're we're prioritizing the
distribution of those but the other
thing and we'll emphasize this with
governor's this afternoon is we're
working with governor's to make sure
that the healthcare providers the
hospitals and the clinics in their state
are placing orders now that this
tremendous increase in supply
particularly with industrial mass is now
available we're going to make sure they
understand that the supply has greatly
expanded thanks to a bipartisan
legislation and the accomplishment the
president and the response by these
companies is making more mass available
and we're gonna make sure healthcare
providers are purchasing those and the
federal government will also make sure
that our stockpile is properly reflects
those increases as well
like today they're available now
the 3m facility that I was at told me in
that in January they went to full
production on 35 million masks the
legislative change means that all 35
million of those that started to be
produced at full capacity in January can
now be sold to hospitals that's the
distinction here it's a very important
change and it's part of the way the
president has been engaging the private
sector pushing the kind of regulatory
reform and the kind of liability reform
that has greatly expanded any second now
they're going to start selling their
marketplace now we're gonna make it
clear to governor's as we made it clear
that health care providers and
conference calls yesterday that those
resources are now there we vastly
increased the supply of medical mass and
we're going to continue to put a
priority on making sure that we're
calling on industry at every level
calling on major suppliers at the
president met with this week to make
sure that those personal protective
equipment are there to do with the
liability becomes amazing how perfect
everybody and much of it had to do with
the liability to the company
thank you - for you in one part dr. Han
the American Hospital Association just
told NBC News that they need a hundred
billion dollars in order to address
shortages in equipment and other
infrastructure there you just find two
legislative packages they say it didn't
directly give money to address this
issue why not and will you commit to me
looking at that issue directly with them
and that's a separate issue but we're
looking at that issue very directly
respond I think we're looking at it very
differently well we're gonna do our best
on it but we're working with Democrats
and Republicans or that we're looking at
that very specifically you bottom-line
people when can Americans expect their
lives to go back to normal will that not
happen until there's a vaccine
I hope very soon we'll see this is
uncharted territory gonna be a while we
think we have ideas and does it help to
say what the ideas I would hope very
soon we're we've pulled together as a
nation people are for the most part
doing what they're supposed to be doing
not in Florida the social distancing is
very interesting a whole new term has
become a hot it's become somewhat of a
hot term but people are instantly there
they're really doing a great job this
country is an amazing country I think
you're up to 141 different countries
right now so it's very uncharted
territory it could have could have been
stopped could have been stopped pretty
easily if we had known if everybody had
known about it a number of months before
people started reading about it excuse
me excuse me before we started reading
about we could have could have been
stopped in its tracks unfortunately they
didn't decide to make it public but the
whole world is suffering because of it
did have a sense that this was a
pandemic that was coming up so why was
the United
we were very prepared the only thing we
weren't prepared for was the the media
the media has not treated it fairly I'll
tell you how prepared I was I called for
a band from people coming in from China
long before anybody thought it was in
fact it was your Network I believe they
called me a racist because I did he
called for the China ban when it was
already in Europe as the center of focus
other words because I did that because I
went so early so when you say we weren't
prepared had I let these tens of
thousands of people come in from China
these Chinese we're gonna go ahead
something right now that would have been
you wouldn't have even recognized it
compared to where we are how many people
have passed away how many people have
died as of this moment you could
multiply that by a factor of many many
many so when you say that I wasn't
prepared I was the first one to do the
band now other countries are following
what I did but the media doesn't
acknowledge that they know it's true
they know it's true but they don't want
to write about it for other personal
protective gloves equipment governors
are saying they don't have access to
respirators and they're terrified what
is your supposed to get it the states is
supposed to get it but we're helping the
states look for years they bought them
and now all of a sudden they're coming
to the federal government we're working
with the states we're working with the
governors we're working with everybody
the relationships are great one of the
things that happened this morning I
spoke with Micky Arison
of Carnival Cruise Lines and he's going
to make ships available so in addition
to the big medical ships that you have
coming if we should need ships with lots
of rooms
they'll be docked at New York and Los
Angeles and San Francisco different
places so I want to thank makeer sand
that's Carnival Cruise Lines
production I've done it yeah if we find
that we need something that we will do
that and you don't know what we've done
you don't know whether or not we've
ordered you don't know if we've invoked
it you don't know what's been ordered
what's not there I can only tell you I
can only tell you that as an example
masks nobody ever heard of the number of
mass that's been ordered they're being
made now and many are available now but
people I think in the media probably
don't know that could you explain the
gap and for the American people and what
you're saying here today about there
being tens of thousands of tests
available about how they're being a huge
amount of masks available and what we're
seeing on the ground which is really the
opposite of that people are people are
saying that they can't get tested even
when they have symptoms people are
saying that they doctors are telling us
they don't have access to vital
equipment can you explain that that gap
well I can't I cannot explain a gap I'm
hearing very good things on the ground
and we're you look like a ramp up they
had an obsolete system and they had a
system simultaneously that was not meant
for this it wasn't meant for this nobody
knew there'd be a pandemic or an
epidemic of this proportion nobody's
ever seen anything like this before
just that he did I can tell you here
that what we're doing is we're working
with local governments with states
governors even mayors on getting them to
be able to get what they need and the
system is starting to work out very well
but we had a breaker system like
breaking an eight because the system we
had was obsolete and didn't work and
that was a system we inherited and now
we have something that's really been
very good and certainly going to be
great for the future too yep
building among professional Republicans
and then your supporters about a
corporate bailout in particular Center
my bronze say if the disco hearken back
to 2008 where we're taking winners and
losers and he and his colleagues may not
be comfortable with that what you single
well we don't want to pick winners and
losers we want everybody to benefit we
want I think more than anything else the
workers the benefit and sometimes for
the worker to benefit you have to go
through the company because they have
thousands of workers and if the company
goes out of business no fault of their
own those workers aren't going to be
able to receive a check so we're look
our ultimate goal or the people our
ultimate goal of the great people of
this country and we will have things
worked out I think that it gonna be very
well it's a very complex formula you
understand that very complex but it's
working out I think it's gonna be very
well I think we're gonna have pretty
uniform support for it please the State
Department is gonna put out an advisory
telling Americans not to travel overseas
at all are you putting in an overseas
travel we're speaking with the State
Department later I can't say right now
because I haven't had the meeting yet I
wanted to ask dr. Hahn about today's
announcement if I do who's
background thank you so much I wanted to
ask out rent rent severe if I pronounced
that correctly can you say is it
currently approved for use on the virus
so Brenda severe and it's a drug made by
Gilead that's been in the press it is
currently in clinical trials here and
around the world we have also made it
available by that approach that I told
you called compassionate use where a
doctor could ask the FDA for that and
the really positive thing about that
that gives it rapidly to a doctor and a
patient but it allows us to collect the
data because what we really need to do
is understand what the data and science
are in order to make the appropriate
decision about safety and effectiveness
so how do you just make sure that it is
safe and I mean is there any concern at
all that it will be safe considering
that it's not going through the normal
process and and could potentially cause
negative effects dr. pouchy earlier
talked about we do not want to put out
anything that could cause a negative
effects is there any concern about those
kind of things with this drugs yeah
thank you for that question because I
just want to be clear about this renessa
vir is going through the normal process
we are using our internal processes at
fda to set up with the company the
protocols to actually collect the data
and you're right we need to actually
know about the safety and the
effectiveness and that's done through
the clinical trial process so it's those
data that are going to inform the
decisions that are ultimately made about
safety and affect see this is an
unprecedented situation this is a really
significant time and one thing that with
the president's leadership fda has done
is said okay how do we approach these
extraordinary times with extraordinary
measures knowing that we have a sacred
trust with the American people about
safety and efficacy but still at the
same time enable these treatments to get
into patients and that's what we're
doing
[Music]
yeah mr. president one for you and one
for the doctors how likely is it that
the 15 day guidance that you would
approve will be extended I can't read
before Tuesday they will have to see
well we'll have indications later on dr.
Burks indicated that there are three
states and ten counties I got that right
where 50% of the cases are focused
should those areas be doing more
measures such as shelter in place I
think they actually are doing a lot I
mean they I know New York is working
very diligently been very strong
I assume San Francisco's one of the
areas in Los Angeles and the state of
Washington obviously that's one that has
to be up there they're all working very
hard to to quarantine or words just
about the equivalent of quarantine your
plan serves more government workers are
you moving for the government as well to
start doing more teleworking we are and
we're doing we're using the medical term
of telemedicine and it's been incredibly
menacing and really you know what people
don't have to ever eat some people can't
do anyway they can enough they can't see
a doctor but we're using this and it's
been telehealth different names and I
will tell you that it's been really
successful it's helped a lot of people
out where they don't have to and they
can't and even from a safety reason if
they are positive they are if they are
feeling poorly they can't do it or we
don't want them transmitting anything to
anybody else on China they reported for
the first time since the outbreak no new
cases over 24 hour period
do you have any reason to disbelieve
them and second to that the National
Security Council yesterday put out a
tweet very critical of the Chinese
government saying the Chinese Communist
Party suppressed initial reports and the
Chinese virus and punished doctors and
journalists causing Chinese and
international experts to miss critical
opportunities to prevent a global
pandemic could you expel it would have
much better if we had known about this a
number of months earlier it could have
been contained to that one area in China
where it started and certainly the world
is paying a big price for what they did
and the world is paying a very big price
but not for not letting them come out
everybody knows that we all know that as
far as as far as believing what they're
putting out now I hope it's true who
knows but I hope it's true possible
you've been talking about China quite a
bit and even talking about the Chinese
virus how if you have heard about this
one day one and had more information
possibly you could have stopped that big
difference are you thinking about any
types of repercussions for China and are
you also rethinking sort of the supply
lines for our manufacturing industry I
don't want to comment on that right now
yeah
I have a question for you and also a
question for dr. Burks at you American
workers across the country are losing
their jobs an unprecedented rate and
your former economist said we could see
some of the worst job numbers ever is
the government prepared to see the spike
in unemployment no worst case scenario
you would have terrible job numbers if
we can get this thing wrapped up and
finished earlier things will go very
nicely and one of the things they're
working as you know one of the elements
that is being worked on very much so in
the hill is to keep the jobs going so
that when we do get rid of the virus
we're going to be able to just really I
think go like a rocket I think the
economy is gonna be fantastic
no remember he said that he was using
that as the ultimate bad outcome I don't
think anybody believes that's gonna
happen for members of Congress are now
being tested positive for echovirus and
you have almost two dozen for self
quarantine
do you have any guidance for Congress
should they I know all of them and I
don't know if they're sitting like you
people are sitting you're actually
sitting too close
you should really we should probably get
rid of about another 75 80 percent of
you I there's two or three that I like
in this room I think that's a great way
of doing it we just begin a new way of
doing it but you're actually much too
close yukky you should leave immediately
but quite look look let them they tested
positive hopefully they're all going to
get better and it's one of those things
it's Congress you know
thank you going to the Heller's to thank
I know somewhere they tested positive
they're in quarantine and I know Lindsey
and many others are they they didn't
test it but until they got the result
they put themselves in quarantine a
number of people in Congress right now
in quarantine they don't know the
results when they get the result they'll
leave this stay there and get better
because people get better I mean most
people are getting better most by far
the people you get better doesn't mean
it's not a tough one it is a tough one
no when many people in Congress have
felt not perfect or they met somebody
that wasn't perfect it turned out to be
positive
lots of people aren't dying they put
themselves in quarantine and I think
that I think Congress has behaved
unbelievably well in that regard do you
think a trillion-dollar stimulus is
enough well know about that we'll see
what happens it depends how long so much
depends on what's going on in this room
in terms of understand that a lot of
these questions like they get asked of
any president and they're not really
fair questions like there's no way to
know now whether a trillion is enough
you're not going to get anything useful
out of them with the idea of the
government taking an equity stake people
are coming people are coming in for
money in some cases no fault of their
own but in some cases where they did
certain things over the course of the
years including by buying back stock you
know they bought back stock and they
paid a high price for it as it turned
out but maybe I view that as a little
bit differently than somebody that
didn't then somebody that bill plants
all over the United States of which
there were plenty of them too airlines
are Boeing or what do you think we will
be helping the airline industry we will
be helping the cruise ship industry we
probably will be helping the hotel
industry will probably be where jobs are
created you don't want to lose
industries like this these are
incredible industries you can't lose
them so we'll be focused on many
industries sounds like to say I can't
say to struggle enough we will be
helping small businesses that's where
it's complicated
because a lot of small you know that's
the engine of the of the country we will
be helping small business these will be
birds that you need to pause this one
trillion dollar stimulus package from
the economy do you expect this to slow
down the delivery of checks for American
families and are you considering any new
executive action that could be we're
looking at a couple of things that I
could do hopefully we won't need it but
we can do was there's a lot of executive
power if we don't have to use it that
would be a good thing not a bad thing
yep pleases Thank You mr. president
one for you and potentially as well one
Fraser got a bunch of dr. Adams right
now the economy is essentially ground to
a halt thanks for telling us the
appreciate stars of closed travel has
slowed down
go ahead what's the rest equation we
know that everybody in the room knows
Trump doesn't like that it is how long
should those who are either not working
right now or business owners who have to
make critical decisions how long should
they expect the state of affairs as it
stands at this moment it's a play out he
said he doesn't know for the doctors
behind you'll be able to tell you that
very I think in the near future we'll
see where we're going you're gonna see
numbers you've seen the graphs you're
gonna see numbers and we'll be able to
let you know I will say that the
American public has been incredible for
the most part not in all cases but for
the most part so you'll be able to see
what's happening over the desk as we say
we had a 15-day period and you'll be
able to tell a lot in a week or so not
everything but will be able to see over
a period of do care for all the parents
that are home right now this
question for dr. Burks or dr. Adams who
are caring for their children and are
curious as to when my kids be able to go
back to school what do you think is a
realistic timeline well I think you know
most of all of those decisions are made
at the state and local government level
and each state and local government has
handled it differently that's why we put
out from the president federal federal
presidential guidance to every single
person about what we think is important
for the next two weeks and as we look at
that data we'll be able to see if it's
having an impact I think you've all seen
the modeling studies those were driven
by the modeling studies showing that you
add these things together they have a
bigger impact than separately and so
those are part of the decision-making we
had a whole group of modelers in
yesterday they're compositing all the
data together to look at this carefully
because everyone has those same
questions of what the impact will be and
what pieces could essentially be removed
and you still have the same level of
impact in decreasing the spread of the
virus the absolute key to this though is
every single American looking at the
president guidelines and taking it
seriously the acts of selflessness that
I am seeing are so impressive across the
board but if even 10 or 15 percent of
the population decides that what they're
doing today is more important than the
health and welfare are the rest of the
marriage that's happening they can
spread the virus in a very strong way
because you know the level of contagion
and I have to say if chloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine works or any of the
other things that they're looking at
they're not quite as far out if they
work your numbers are going to come down
very rapidly oh that's a there's a real
chance that they might I was hoping he
would not just so sunday was taking
photos with supporters in gorging mass
demonstration and just yesterday
president from brazil said that we
should not be surprised if we see him in
the next few days in a crowded subway in
Sao Paulo wasn't real because he is the
president it should view the people what
do you think about that it was your
message well he's a friend of mine
number one and number two we had dinner
the other night and everybody said he
was positive and he wasn't positive I'm
dr. drew that was I was quite happy when
I heard that but I have no message for a
mother than he's doing a good job in
Brazil I can't tell you about that I
don't know about that I have not heard
that he's doing a very good job Brazil
was very troubled before he got there
and he's the people loved him and it's
popular I think he's doing a very good
job
there are Americans who were traveling
abroad or essentially stuck unable to
come home we spoke to a green beret ten
women who Americans to where well we
spoke to ten American women who were in
Morocco for instance all the flights
have been cancelled their hotel is
shutting down they literally have no
place to stay and no way to get home
they are asking you they're asking the
administration the US government for
help what can be done we know about it
we have groups we have a group of young
people in in Peru and we're working on
taking care of that with the military so
yeah we're looking to take down that
evacuation we're we're trying to get
them out and you know they got caught
they were late with their flights we
gave them a period of time they didn't
make it but we're looking to get them
out with military probably through the
military we have a group of young young
people I think young men or young people
could be women also with them from
Alabama the great state of Alabama and
Peru and we're working on that right now
trying to get them out it's a large
group it's about 300 well we're gonna
work it out yeah - president - sort of
foreign policy related questions and
your talk with the g7 leaders earlier
this week did you discuss together and
or postponing human things yeah we
discuss it as you know Prime Minister
Robby was on the call and that's a big
decision for him and we don't know what
his decision is but we'd live with this
decision it's a tough situation they've
done an incredible job
Japan has done an incredible job when
building the venues getting them built
you know you've seen so many Olympic
venues that have been a disaster over
the years where they cost five times
more than they were supposed to they
weren't ready in time Japan has been
just the opposite
they built it beautifully they built it
for what it was supposed to be built for
but then he got hit with the same thing
that the rest of the world got hit with
unexpectedly he has he has told us that
he has not made a decision as to what to
do so on foreign policy have you spoken
to the leaders of Saudi Arabia or Russia
and encouraged them to stop this glut of
oil that is detected in the market well
the one thing I will tell you is that
from the stand point you always get a
little bit torn because you know until
we became the leading producer I was
always for the person driving the car
and filling up the tank of gas and you'd
have gasoline and the prices were if
they were too high I would always raise
hell with OPEC and I was always somebody
that liked saying I never thought I'd
see 22 and 24 and 28 dollars a barrel
but that's what we have and in one way
our consumer is very much helped it's
like it's like a massive tax increase
that's bigger than any tax increase
decrease that you could give you know we
can give all these big tax cuts but
they're paying so little for people
aren't driving around keep gas prices
done deal and it hurts a great industry
and a very powerful industry so I spoke
with numerous people that have a lot to
do with it and we have a lot of power
over the situation and we're trying to
find some kind of a medium ground you
know it's it's very devastating to
Russia because when you look I mean the
whole economy is based on that and they
have we have the lowest oil prices in
decades so it's very devastating to
Russia I would say it's very bad for
Saudi Arabia but they were in a fight
they were in a fight on price they were
in a fight on output
and at the at the appropriate time I'll
get involved if I missed it hopefully
the Carnival cruise ships be used for
well Mickey called up and he said if you
need them and we haven't said yes I'll
call Governor Cuomo I'll I'll call Gavin
from gavin newsom governor from
california I'll call a few of the other
governors they're gonna bring it up
today because we're meeting through
phone through telephone telephonically
as they say we call it a phone the law
FEMA I'm going out of FEMA from here
well you could increase places to stay
let's say places to stay if it works I
mean you know I don't know maybe people
won't want him but he made the offer it
was a very generous offer and he said
that he has some ships that would be
ideally suited for what we're doing and
certainly they have a lot of rooms
they're big and they have a lot of rooms
so we appreciate it from Carnival
quite in the future will any American
who wants to test be able to get a test
because you're talking about not eating
a test right now if you're not showing
any symptoms but a lot of eating the
tests are only getting tested if you're
showing symptoms but a lot of this no
you should only good
we should I didn't have any symptoms
that I got a test but I got a test
because you people were driving
everybody crazy Louise I had no symptoms
but I had a test and my doctor told me
don't get it you don't need it nasty
blood you don't need it but I had to do
it because the press was going crazy and
then after I got it they said you
shouldn't have gotten it you had no
symptoms you know the whole thing so in
other words if you get it it was Duggar
but that's I'm a unique guy the case
unfortunately but no people that don't
show symptoms and people that have
doctors that say they shouldn't get it I
would rely on that yeah I would - I
don't think it's racist I don't think
it's racist at all
on that note major lesbian news media
even
teamed up with Chinese Communist Party
narratives oh my god kick her out get
away you are consistently citing oh my
god dicker out anywhere right here at
the White House with direct access to
you like this is what we need now it
amazes me when I read the things that I
read it amazes me when I read the Wall
Street Journal which is always so
negative it amazes or not when I read
the New York Times is not even I don't I
barely read it you know we don't
distribute it in the White House anymore
in the same thing with the Washington
Post right Amazon Jeff because you see I
know the truth
and people out there in the world they
really don't know that they don't know
what it is they use different slogans
and different concepts for me almost
every week trying to catch something
last week it was all chaos you see me
there's no K I said no chaos I'm the one
telling everybody to be calm there's no
chaos of the White House we have
unbelievable professionals it's really I
mean I think I came up with the term I
hope I came up with the term but it is
faked as it's more than fakeness it's
corruptness they write stories without
calling anybody they write a story today
I had a couple of stories where they
never call me how does he know if he's
not reading the story at least nobody
tells me they'll write a story about me
without even asking my opinion on
something it's totally fake I've never
seen I mean there is a story in the Wall
Street Journal today about you know
about how we've done we've done a
phenomenal job on this the governors
rivers even Gavin Newsom who you know
I'm usually fighting with over the fires
and I think you should do a different
kind of a job at that in the forests and
lots of things we've we argue a lot but
Gavin Newsom has been very very generous
generous Andrew Cuomo has been really
very generous I mean they're saying
we're doing a great job and everybody's
saying but then you read this
faint phony story in the Wall Street
Journal or where the Washington Post is
going wild lately I don't know what
happened to them I guess something
happened like we don't
all aback or whatever but the Washington
Post these are very dishonest media
sources they're very dishonest and you
know what someday hopefully in five
years I won't be here and that'll be
fine I will have done I think a great
job because I don't think anyone's done
as much in three and a half years as
I've done you know think and the
administration this administration has
done that jack but the press is very
dishonest well I think they do I mean I
mean they are siding with they are
siding with China they are kinda things
that they shouldn't be doing deciding
with many others China is the least of
it so why why they're doing this you'll
have to ask them but if we had an honest
media in this country our country would
be an even greater place so ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much we are
very excited about
clora you're very excited about in
specifically from reservoir what we
talked about with the chloroquine I
think the I think it could be something
really incredible it could totally
depress the times that we had mentioned
wait excuse me excuse me it could
totally depress that we're talking about
if it works there are a lot of reasons
that I have to believe again dr. Han is
the expert but a lot of reasons that I
would have to think that it could have a
very positive effect or a positive
effect maybe not very but maybe maybe
positive I think it's to me very very
exciting and the beauty is I think I can
say this Steve the beauty is that these
drugs have been out there so they're
really danger part of the drugs
especially chloroquine it's been out
there for years
so we've almost 100 it's something that
can be taken safely so it's very
important
[Music]
go ahead said it maybe more how quickly
do you think
well the president has asked us to
expedite this and what I want to assure
you because of the questions that were
asked we want to make sure that this is
done well and right for the American
people the president is right with an
off-the-shelf drug we do have a lot of
information about the side effects of
the drug so that really helps in terms
of expediting but but I want to show you
that we're working as quickly as we can
I don't want to speculate about a
timeline at this point with respect to
vaccines that's in phase one trial as I
mentioned we're expecting that to
proceed moving forward and we're working
with a number of different other
companies about vaccine development
one was fast-tracked is it possible
phase 2 and phase 3 can be fast-tracked
that we might see a vaccine before that
year you get used it it could
potentially be this is a terrific
question and we are really trying hard
at FDA to partner with great industry
great academic partners to do exactly
that
no promises can be made but one thing
that we're doing is really working hard
to try keeping this guide fair
have other times to meet will be meeting
hopefully not for very long I mean it
would like to see this get cleared up
and we think we've to me this was a very
important conference because I really
think there's great potential here and a
lot of people are gonna be trying it
soon like literally very soon literally
in a matter of days if not sooner in
some cases it's already being
experimented with and there's been some
very good results we'll see what happens
but if if we can be even partially right
maybe we'll be fully right but even
partially right on it
this whole subject becomes a much more
pleasant subject so thank you all and
we'll we're going over to FEMA now so I
don't know who's going but we're going
to FEMA we're gonna be discussing with
the governors and lots of other people
cut it
hence making sure to grab those papers
trump's been spitting on this entire
time alright so another press conference
in the books I do want to thank
everybody who grabbed memberships while
this was going on if you're heading out
and you're watching on YouTube or twitch
remember to follow like and subscribe
it's free I really do appreciate it if
you're if you're heading out let me
quickly thank Michael Rogers whose new
member number 13 today Monica van Leeuw
shout who is new member number 14 david
Ladda
or latte who is new member number 15
Deven Shah is number 16 at join
pakman.com john paneros is new member
number 17 roberta pace Thank You Roberta
is number 18
Lisa Shelton new member number 19 who
signed up while Trump was chatting there
renee blatte ler is new member number 20
Monica Pruett number 21 and that is a
that is it that is everybody remember if
you've been watching my show all week
you already know about chloroquine
you might even already know about
chloroquine combined with zip as if
throw Meissen in a test you would
already know about REM dez aveer you
wouldn't be calling it rum reservoir as
the president did but if you didn't
maybe maybe there was some news there
we've got to get back to today's
production of the show we will continue
streaming the press conferences as they
happen